go for it three two one
yes you got it everybody Steven Brody
Stevens back here again recording
another top-notch sports lifestyle 47
year old male living in a North
Hollywood apartment podcast we are here
right now
now that's not I see it a thing is that
just four levels I see the zoom yeah
this is we're on the road folks we're
seeing different technology I see it
it's a zoom mic this is when you if you
have a podcast the law is you have to
buy a zoom microphone they're available
at the Guitar Center and it doesn't say
that's recording are we recording on it
now we're recording was that on and all
the other stuff oh it's just a backup
see we're all backup I focused on the
backup generator because I am in that
mode where I'm I'm saving up food I am
looking to go into a bunker so
everything's got a backup that backup
has a backup you think the zoom mic is
the back I have a backup zoom zoom that
goes into my phone and if that doesn't
work I will take my old iPhone and
record the zoom it's just it just keeps
going it's infinity you keep pushing you
keep pushing and you go to the different
levels and not everybody season that's
why it's called trailblazing they don't
get it they'll turn on you Brody where
are you going I go trust my instincts I
get it I went to school in Arizona not
afraid to go into the mountains you know
everyone thinks the desert is just you
know cactus and tumbleweed you can go
into the hills and you know people talk
about you know la you know an hour to
the desert an hour to the snow an hour
to the the beach an hour to this same
thing in Arizona you can go to Salt
River that's 45 minutes away I can go
down the tube drinking beer on a tube I
can go to Flagstaff go skiing I'm sure
there's snow up there I can go deep into
the Grand Canyon you have options here
in Arizona and they want to keep it
quiet they go oh you're in the middle of
nowhere I'm sick of rattlesnakes I saw a
guy here yesterday's a prominent
member of the Los Angeles comedy
community and he's never spent time here
in Arizona he goes I don't like the
desert I go how dare you is that al
Madrigal that is on that ladies and
gentlemen one of the top players I would
a possible CEO he's got labels and
initials next to his name he's a guy who
has always been a supporter he's a big
sports guy I believe his wife is a
Atlanta Braves fan he is
she's Yankees now would she have one
point a Braves fan Sarah Tiana and you
were you married to Sarah Tiana at one
point there you go al Madrigal godmother
religious not afraid to mention God
that's what that's what living in
Pasadena does for you you will mention
God look at Al the hair the goatee the
teeth the Hat I see al probably every
not enough five to six months maybe you
stopped because you will you have kids
so you made a choice al Madrigal to stop
doing stand-up at The Comedy Store at
night I mean you can hop on the mic you
know these are called podcasts al I'm
glad you hear they sent you here this is
an emergency booking this guy saving the
network yeah you don't see Tim Cook from
Apple you don't see Bill Gates come in
and and fiddle with the Microsoft the
their hardware and all that stuff and
this app this guy is here al Madrigal so
yeah I just I see my kids growing up 15
and 11 and now they're going to bed
later and it's just uh I see timewise
that it's just all going you know all my
time with them is going away so I'm just
trying to be present as a father are you
doing like afternoon gigs is there like
there's no date no daytime lunchtime
brunch comedy no there's no matinee that
they can get ahold of so do you think
they should do something like that
that'd be great actually people who
don't want to go out maybe that's
something we could explore some sort of
daytime gig or people just don't like
just a once in a while once a month to
do a 5 p.m. show
inside create like an atmosphere where
people just it's the early bird special
for people you're saying five I was
saying like twelve to one like well
that's too early lunch stand up like you
know in between dropping the kids off I
mean you have to have a you have to be a
parent
these are the laws yeah I just I'm
watching what I got to see is they could
see parents with older kids I mean Oscar
Morales is one of them you just see how
quickly time goes by and so I'll have
mad at a house in no time then I'll get
right back to it is that so you're
waiting for like in sixth year when the
kid the eleven-year-old I'll still do it
and I do it on the road but yeah I'm
just being away every single night you
just sort of watch you know I spent so
many years on the road doing stand-up
that's how I made a living from he's
like 2003 to 2004 I got the Daily Show
2010 mm-hmm I was on the road that
entire time with little kids so I was
gone constantly and I missed a lot of
the first moments I missed a lot of you
know baseball games I missed a lot of
basketball games I missed all the dad
stuff that people who work regular
nine-to-five you know sort of take for
granted so I just watched them growing
up so fast it's very boring but anyway
I'm not no but that's it that's what the
you know baseball players say that they
miss these guys they retire from
baseball and their early to mid-30s and
a lot of them say that they want to
spend time with their families they
didn't get it opportunity yeah you
realize after nine years of doing
stand-up on the road that you missed
somebody's entire childhood yeah so does
it make it better through FaceTime and
all that stuff and you watch you're a
child birth through live streaming no
you couldn't do anything but my wife was
cool so she won't I got Montreal
did just for last new faces which is
like the NBA's should have draft of
stand-up comics my son was supposed to
be born on the same that that was the
due date right when I got new faces
uh-huh and she's like yeah you gotta go
you gotta so she was gonna be cool with
me missing my son's birth or some of
these comedy wives are they
you know there get hard on the husband
like hey you got to be here you know
know well you got to get your comedy
wife before you get it shoot it there's
a trick to that yeah actually you want
it it's too late for you because
somebody's gonna attach themselves to
Brody Stevens and Ikes they want they
didn't catch you now you've gotten all
the success and so maybe they won't love
you for who you really are
but when you meet yeah but that's why
this is who I yeah I know what you're
saying you're I am right now
so with stand-up you want to be
established as a stand-up but not
successful maybe that's me know you're
super successful what are you talking
about well I mean in non-union cable
credits sure I mean where's the network
money al where's the Netflix money
where's the crackle this crackle still
around yeah I think they've just had an
essential thing that was it yeah they
did right you know where's he knowing
what I'm saying is like there's this
sort of sweet spot for somebody who
you're established as a stand-up comic
they know it's your dream they know you
have to do this they know it's what you
do what they signed up for yeah and
they're part of it at the same time and
then you also don't want somebody who I
think if you it's like a midlife crisis
if somebody decides that they want to
become a stand-up after they're already
in this established relationship then
that's not gonna work so it's it's not
gonna work stand-up wise or relaxed it's
gonna be layin ship you're gonna have a
wife going what are you doing why are
you going out every night what about me
and you know and you just Lee I think
when you you look like you're like sort
of fleeing the relationship at that
point yeah it's it's tricky but my wife
and I know I talked to other comics
about this is that when you have a
stand-up wife when we're around too much
they sort of want you gone like they're
they like you leaving every once in a
while yeah so it is absence makes the
heart grow fonder and there is a good
balance to doing stand up on the road
and take it off so it's a but I feel
like a family if I didn't have a family
I would definitely be dead
you would electrum like party big yeah
sure so they keep you yeah ground I
don't want you're responsible for I do
try to I'm trying to set a good example
over there
I can't see I don't have an I don't I
don't
oh yeah I'm alike I don't have too many
I'm not married obviously and I wasn't
but I feel that when I do comedy if a
girl sees me do comedy at least she's
seen me that way whereas like if she
meets me outside of yeah yeah like our
bar box or the grocery store in the
frozen food section and then she talks
to me and half the time they don't think
I'm funny anyway cuz I'm kind of shy
actually in public I don't I'm not big I
don't walk into Starbucks
ye-yes I'll take a treinta you got it
I'm very quiet so then when they see
that I do I mention comedy oh you're
fine I can't see that but then if they
see my comedy or they see my
live-streaming or their fans in the
podcast I kind of a kind of like just
get some they're up to speed and then
what they are seen on stage is an
extension of me maybe is the real me
I've come out of my shell now I haven't
talked to you about this at all what is
your dating life like and do you or I
was intimate two weeks ago that was cool
the last time I made love was in Denver
what were the circumstances do you mind
discussing in the lovemaking just how
did you meet this individual like weird
the last walk us through the whole thing
as a Brodie fan I want to know how you
met or where your do you did she know
your standup she approaches you well you
know comedies popular these days and
it's probably a good idea you know The
Comedy Store is yeah there's I don't
know if Chris D'Elia is bringing in all
these chicks but comedy is the new rock
and roll sure so there's a Brody fan
that finds you she's well aware of who
you are and she's you I mean look at my
crowd yeah I see it it's 50/50 I got
half guys half women through the crowd
is if just to describe what we've got
here just an equal amount of women two
men in the audience yes yes we do and I
do I do have female fans I've noticed
that and they you know they're in
relationships
that's one thing but some that I do have
I'm probably gonna end up with like a
divorced woman with a child and I'm
gonna come in and I'm gonna be that that
stepfather baseball mitt right away yeah
and I play baseball cuz I understand I
know how to throw a baseball I know how
to catch a baseball that's all I you
know judge comedians Oh your your this
way on stage here I have a glove in my
my trunk of my car let's play catch in
the comedy store parking lot and let's
see how you throw the ball and then they
go oh look how I throw let me say you
catch it that's another thing you could
tell you know everyone talks about how
they throw but if you throw a ball and
they're moving out of the way they're
doing that with the club you're afraid
of the bass you snap it do you know no I
don't think many players I mean maybe
the middle infielders they'll snap it
because they're always like tag but as a
pitcher
I'm very methodical got a four seams to
the chest
catch and I learned that from my friend
who's a major league baseball coach with
the Cubs and you went to Wrigley Field
rice right on I had great I went with
Demetri Martin Christian Shah on Brody
completely set us up and I said you guys
up with the tickets so get back to the
Denver girl oh we're back to that okay
oh well that was to be honest the last
couple women have been based out of
comedy I've kind of dipped into that you
know comedy that's a comedy fan but it's
great I don't like approaching women I
don't I can't what I was starting I've
been doing comedy for about a year prior
to meeting my wife and I was not some
guy who could walk up to a girl in a bar
and and start making conversation
without feeling creepy about it so I am
by yourself for a way yeah no Vince
Vaughn from swingers you know I'm not
able to be super charming in a nightclub
situation so you ever have a wingman
with you I mean that's what it's yeah
nice very good with groups being
properly introduced and getting a chance
to talk to somebody great but you know
trying to have a conversation in a loud
bar never never I was never into that
that's something one thing I talk about
you know you drive by these clubs on the
strip or just bars or whatever and they
love to old I was never
mm-hmm not possible I was never into it
and I like hanging out at the comedy
clubs they're like the new boys like I'd
rather hang out at the comedy club then
go to a bar no people want to go to bars
and party but you got to be able to hear
we're comedians we don't want to scream
it scream and yell but yes
not honest with you I I do have because
I'm real they're seeing a real guy for
the most especially through my live
streaming in my podcast because you're
getting the real even though I'm a
little amped right now so a lot of
people feel like oh it's my comedy act I
feel like maybe my life is an act and my
comedy is real oh my gosh that's a quote
yep write it down so so back to that
that girl I think it's just confidence
and you know she's and she's I'm not
going I'm not like a crazy guy I mean I
got to be careful what am i Weinstein
are you trying to put my back get me in
trouble oh there's a lot of I just saw a
bunch of sexual harassment stuff come
out of with comics do you see this are
you serious give me some names if it's
probably it's public knowledge
I don't know well everyone knows that
there's a couple that they know of they
know for sure right true but they're new
guys coming out or new gals helpful new
guys not gals and then well there's this
gum always a skeevy comedy guy who's a
producer rick nájera
yeah rick Najera he was a guy who was
just sort of this bottom feeder Latino
comedian Wrangler that wormed his way
into CBS diversity so he just got into
trouble yeah I saw that
okay so he got properly kicked out I
sent that guy my demo tape so I'm not
gonna hear about you're not getting her
back I was trying to get into CBS
diversity is a older non Bar Mitzvah
Jewish guy Jewish Yemen I was born
Jewish raised Yemenite so I'm just
saying with with you though it's a lot
of women ever approaching you and it's
great yes I like that and as I mentioned
I think because they see the periscope
they see the stand up they hear the
podcasting and there see yeah they're
seeing
real real stuff and that's why I think
that to come you know you're not there
as much
III can give you it's how I met my wife
though I've met my wife had a show she
was in the audience she was a friend
do you remember Brian Jarvis I remember
the name so Brian Jarvis as a friend of
her from hers from work and she came out
to see stand-up I saw her in the
audience I inquired and she said she
didn't want anything to do with the
stand-up comic
she was actually working at a school for
homeless children so I went to go sort
of you know stop by court her and really
sort of Ward down and got around a
couple of dates yeah married a year and
a half later you want to date it was
this in the Bay Area yeah where'd you
guys go
Red Robin what's that no I worked at Red
Robin so I was into Red Robin in plenty
of times you know they have one in
Burlingame I think that's already good a
Red Rock I worked at the original Red
Robin in Seattle Washington yeah that's
where it started Seattle started Costco
Starbucks Microsoft Starbucks Red Rock
Red Robin
Amazon Seattle WA it was uh for me was a
great comedy town I went up there and
that's where I learned to public speak I
sold t-shirts for the Seattle
SuperSonics we're talking about coming
out of our shell I think it's one of my
first gig was in Pioneer Square at that
comedy underground two great blocks gig
so barely paid yeah I think I made it
might open for Swardson very very really
impossible yeah the comedy underground
in Seattle that was the spot one of the
great spots in comedy did we're up there
Joey Diaz was up there Josh wolf was up
there mitch hedberg for a time Craig
Gass myself and Seattle was kind of like
that you know like like Triple A for San
Francisco now that to see I'm just such
a big 40 in the San Francisco 49er fan I
hate the Seahawks so much that I can't
bear to go back I hate everything about
that team and so it's sort of ruined
Seattle for me what do you think about
so your mom Niners fans yeah obviously
what do you think about that and do you
think they lost it by moving to
to Santa Clara to that Levi's Stadium I
just don't think there was any other
choice because the city was so fickle
with you know it having the stadium be
100% privately funded and just it was in
the neighborhood that grew Candlestick
was so horrible was one of the worst
neighborhoods in San Francisco was
called double rock so you just had crime
ridden projects surrounding that area
and here we have an amusement park Sonny
and tear down the the apartments yeah
kick all the people out well you know I
fly over I flew into San Francisco or
just like not seeing Candlestick Park
out there which is weird and there's so
much but it was a total and for
anybody who went there on a regular
basis it was a big dump it was one of
the oldest stadiums in the NFL there was
just violence everywhere I went to a
Raider and 49er game it was a preseason
game where two guys got shot I was
escorting my dad out cuz Raiders fans
are all savages and the Niner fans are
really no better and so they I saw a big
Samoan guy smashing a guy's head against
a sink oh that's nice yeah so I
heard about that out yeah they said they
couldn't have those two teams played
right there was like basically two rival
gangs meeting in the Bay Area's what it
came down to and when the 49ers are
doing shitty everybody sells their seats
and so maybe last I think last year the
cowboy game that I went to was one of
the worst sports experiences I've ever
had in my entire life so when yours team
sucks like we do now the opposing fans
get to come in and when they did that in
Candlestick it was just a gang fight it
was so I mean um so anyway they can't
link was a big dump but I'm happy to see
it couldn't they but what I'm saying is
they went down to Santa Clara it's like
you take you're taking that aura that
magic that happened you know Joe Montana
to Dwight Clark all did people did the
players not like playing at Candlestick
I bet you they they didn't care I mean
they probably liked the facilities but
you're only playing eight home games
it's not I'm not saying the Giants
should have stayed there they're good
with where they moved I'm saying I think
San Francisco
and I'm a la guy but I think they lost
it by moving just like kind of the
Yankees they didn't have to redo the new
Yankee Stadium with San Francisco as the
real estate is that there's just not
much of it so there's not many places to
go and there's an old Navy shipyard that
where they were out in that sort of
double rock area but there just weren't
many places for them to go and there's a
lot of it sucking landfill and so
structurally I just think it was
difficult let you do it and I think were
you going down they have the new where's
arena they're building yeah they're
there but if you walk down through that
neighborhood you'll see it's also the
foundations of all the buildings are
cracked and separated from the sidewalk
it's all sinking it's a problem so I'm
just not sure I don't know about how how
just how feasible it was for them to
build such a large facility you know you
take 20,000 seats and you get a
basketball Stadium that's one thing but
to put 72,000 people or whatever a
football stadium is and put it downtown
I think that would be pretty tough
well the downtown football stadium I
don't know there's talk you know they're
talking about putting the in la the
stadium downtown yeah weird Staples is
right and where it was all of the
conventions yeah and they couldn't make
that word III think that I thought it
would have been kind of cool to put the
NFL stage for sure said the farmers
field is what they wanted to do downtown
but now World Series what do you think
is gonna happen right now in the middle
of the World Series it's Game four is
coming up today you know it's Dodgers
are down two to one Astros lead the
series two to one passed out of seven
it's a must win for the Dodgers I feel
like today is the must-win because if
they want to they're down 3-1 now you're
in Houston Game five and they bring it
down there there anyway they haven't
lost it in at home right they haven't
lost in dissent that stadiums loud they
have the roof that left-field is weird
that's the one thing I don't like about
that ballpark down and Houston that
minim aid is that left field is like 315
feet it's it's it's kind of a joke
meaning like you can just hit a flyball
to left
and it's gone and I feel that kind of
takes the game it's a little bit little
weird for me and then I also you know
it's a good series I'm not taking away
I'm because you're obviously a big
Dodger fan but what who do you root for
when the Cubs play the Dodgers it's hard
it's very hard I'm uh I'm torn because
my friend who I grew up with you know my
little league baseball childhood he's
yeah professional major-league baseball
coach and he's with the Cubs and he's
been there now for five or six years and
I get access I'm privy to inside
information they let me suit up but you
know I grew up in LA my heart is with
the Dodgers you know my friend tomorrow
it's not gonna happen or next year could
go say work for the Baltimore Orioles I
would support the Orioles you know but
and it's hard when the Cubs played the
Dodgers in fact I don't even go to the
game I don't try I don't want to be
around because even when they playing a
regular-season game if I talk to some of
the Dodger guys oh what are you doing
over there they'll like and then same
thing with the Dodgers if I talk to cups
Oh Brody you're a front-runner and I
know they're goofing they're pushing
buttons cuz they they do like me but it
does I am a little uncomfortable with it
to be honest with you but I also you
know I could get a job in baseball I
like to be you know agents work with all
different players and different ranks
and then there's mental skills guys and
that's kind of what I'd like to get into
is the mental approach the positive
energy the unlicensed therapist guy you
know you can go talk to me like you're
having a problem with that teammate
Brody how would you handle it well is a
I played baseball you're gonna take the
high road you got to be you know it's so
much mental and that's the other thing
you see these Justin Turner for example
with the Dodgers who's on fire
you know with the red beard and all that
he's got he went to Cal State Fullerton
and that's where he learned about
positive energy visualization in fact
the guy who taught him visualization can
Reviva is now with the Cubs so if you
study Justin Turner he learned about
basic
mental preparation from kenra visa who's
with the Cubs who was with me at Arizona
State so it's all you say your hunt
you're almost home with being back at
Arizona and Arizona so you're very close
to where you went to played baseball yes
but I have to tell you this in terms of
the positive energy my buddy is a PhD
and that's what he specialized in really
yeah so he specialized in the psyche s
sport psychology and when I first
started doing stand-up comedy he was
just finishing getting that degree and
he was telling me just about visualizing
success with stand-up and walking out on
the stage and imagining the end result
and so just usually you could use it
with everything right I mean do you find
that's basic
well I handle because I played baseball
five years team sports all through and
then when I started doing I would say
audience warmup is when I was able to
take those principles I learned in
baseball the visualization and then
because I was with a sport show best
damn sports show so I would have
football teams and baseball teams all
the high schools all the community
college and I was able to just provide I
put some of that energy out and I saw
that it affected the show and they liked
it that the coaches liked when I got on
the players like sitting up being
finding the funny you know and when they
were into it the show rocked it was
tight but when they're like slouchy not
you know lights would go out they mess
up on the teleprompter so I really
learned it and I saw the results of the
positive energy and then it just started
picking up but I got it from college
because I hated running I knew like my
freshman year would be like oh we got to
run a time mile and just like ruined my
day and then the second year I said okay
I got to start being positive and we
learned about visualization about
positive affirmations you could never
say to somebody don't strike out when
you're played baseball Arizona State or
college baseball when you're a pitcher
you have to be on that front rail in the
game talking pushing ragging a little
bit of the other team so here's always
in and we would joke about
how we could be positive with numbers
words all of that stuff and we saw
results and I my running got better and
then when I when I was a Y played sports
I mean when I did the warm-up that I saw
these guys going off to do so because I
was you think there's not only do it not
only something to you being positive but
other people being positive about to you
so into sort of a crowd mentality if a
good large portion of the people with
the audience that we have here yeah
believe strongly in right we're sending
you prom positive vibes it's gonna be a
better podcast it's giving a feed off
yeah what first its energy so if even if
it's negative energy you're putting out
energy and then we tweak it to being
positive and I'm saying like I also
learned about it when I moved up to
Seattle so I when I was done with
college I took an acting class a comedy
class at UCLA the only went up to
Seattle I met Tina my friend I know if
you know Dana Manu who's a Samoan guy he
lived down here in Phoenix also we lived
in Seattle
he was Samoan he was Mormon so he didn't
curse and he was very happy see Romero I
played in this sports world that was
around you know conservative Aryan white
anti-semitic almost and I just dealt
with it you know that's just how it was
so I learned not complaining actually
you know when I played it issues like
freshmen are to be seen not heard so if
they're anti-semitic you have to take it
no but that's kind of what I did and I
felt like they're trying to like push my
buttons weed me out and I was going like
I'm a nice guy you know three months ago
in high school everyone liked me it's
popular now I come here and I'm a weirdo
that's not on me that's on you guys so I
just kind of waited that out and I
applied that also to comedy but what I
learned with Dana was just like being
happy but like let the other guys win I
pay for teasing on you've been extremely
well-liked because in the comedy
community I just think very well-liked
well of course very nice tonight people
take advantage you think so I'm too nice
I've always been a nice guy you know
growing up in the valley I was nice and
I saw that like people would kind of
make fun of me for being nice it didn't
feel good to be remember they pick on me
for smiling
this isn't growing up and this is
growing up in Tarzana in an apartment
building divorced parents
you know kids riding bikes this is in
the 70s and then I got picked on but you
know what doing comedy for me once I
found out it just made it all worth it
same thing with this baseball getting
picked on or you know I just I didn't
they weren't malicious but when I once I
took a acting class and was around
supportive it was like ah this is great
but if I was always in that supportive
environment growing up if my mom put me
in acting classes or whatever I think I
would have had more of a I don't know it
wouldn't be as such a discovery for me
cuz I never did comedy I never eaten in
college I mean I went to Arizona State
Tempe I never set foot in the Tempe
improv I was so focused on getting
everything I could out of baseball and
then graduating but you were a comedy
fan the intact I'm not even not really I
mean growing up I liked Benny Hill I
liked wrestling I was into baseball I
could tell you everything about stats
stadiums I was aware of comedy and then
in college we liked Andrew Dice Clay but
I think my mind maybe the way I was
because I have adult onset Asperger's
the way my mind work it was is like
maybe on the you know the spectrum the
autism spectrum cable spectrum cable but
yeah so that's why I probably good a
warm up I was so good at 3,000 warm ups
and I forgotten forget but like my stand
up suffered somewhat same thing with
this baseball yeah I have full access
with the Cubs I can go wherever I want I
get to suit up now am I getting paid no
no not really
am I making friendships and all that am
i unknown as a baseball guy yeah cuz I
went all out for it but maybe somebody
who's like a little more mature or older
to go you know what I have respond
abilities maybe you could have channeled
it into a nicer so what I'm saying is do
you know gar - does the the batting
practice guy yes they are you friends
with him yeah we're really good friends
a big word hey you got Sam Triple E in
here we buy this is a party folks we are
talking sports we are talking lifestyle
growing up we talked bass keep going out
with positive energy we're talking about
just sort of origin stories a little bit
we're talking about relationships do you
know that Brody is doing quite well for
himself socially in Denver yeah you know
mile high you know things you know I'm I
get chicks once and I'm confident I am a
posture I take apple cider vinegar
that's the one they can see that I get a
reaction here takes apple cider vinegar
show of hands we have it I take it you
don't take it I've taken it but I don't
take it I drink a little shot of it
I put apple cider vinegar in my treinta
right here no I'm joking but I take
three tablespoons of apple cider vinegar
mix it with some some juice Oh Sam's
gotta take a call in the middle my apple
cider vinegar bet this could help you
what are their vitamins are you I think
do you talk about this at length but
what else are you taking what it like in
terms of a regimen okay talk to us all
about this because you seem like a great
person to consult okay thank you yes my
regimen is in the morning right now I
take two branch chain amino acids BCAA
because amino acids are the building
blocks of the body so I take branch
chain amino acids some glutamine in the
morning just to help with the blood
sugar and then I take a scoop of Reds
scoop of greens another scoop of protein
and colon cleanse shake it up with water
so howhow do you get all your greens
every day can you do five servings of
greens no no not at all this is what I'm
asking that's why you need a scoop of
miracle greens
fifty dollars I have a promo code also
miracle rents how I mean can you eat
five servings of beets and Red's and all
that you can't physically now is
impossible but what I'm saying is when I
take that I feel it I feel it in my
hands my nails my skin these things you
do feel it and then also I take
l-arginine and I'm only saying this
stuff because when I go onstage people
say ho Brodie you're you're in shape you
look good you and it's is this something
you could post somewhere because I also
I know people couldn't write this down
and rewind and listen to her off the
podcast would be nice to have a list and
also the time day and just sort of a
regular sort of schedule maybe somewhat
a JPG yeah put a post a JPEG but I think
it works because I'm not sick
knock on wood I haven't you know people
constantly comment on it so I think it's
posture it's stretching its visualizing
that's the other thing what's all about
visualize I visualize that I'm in good
shape
I don't I haven't done cardio for
probably seven months I haven't touched
a kettlebell for seven months but I take
l-arginine which is a precursor for
nitric oxide now why do I take nitric
oxide because I have heart disease in my
family my mother quadruple bypass father
to double bypasses uncle's stents it's
in my know we have I'm half Mexican half
Sicilian everybody has heart disease
exactly we're predisposed but l-arginine
is opens up your veins
it helped us helps us blood flow how do
you get how do you get your vein I
didn't take it this morning and you can
tell my my you can't see them if I took
l-arginine I'd have a pump in my arm so
I take L arginine but it's got to be
expensive so all this it's cheap at
$7.99 at Vitamin Shoppe in fact Sam's
podcast partner Ryan has an in at
Vitamin Shoppe I can go to Vitamin
Shoppe and get Ryan's promo code and
save some money I'm only going on these
supplements because I think they work I
started taking calcium bone up by djaro
they're an Israeli
they're popular they're an Israeli brand
they're based in LA I take the calcium I
used to have like my teeth would be like
loose I started taking the calcium
my teeth are strong no cavities I I bear
here's the other thing I brush my teeth
maybe one probably once a day sometimes
two no cavities and I could what I'm
saying I can tell I'm getting cavities
at night now how about the libido when
you are we don't have their women um I
mean I can get yeah I was I was really
proud of myself I'm not gonna say names
but I was really rocking it the other
night a lot of compliments well yeah
confidence passion compliments
compliments yeah compliments passion
squeezing we have a Sam Tripoli question
is there dirty talk are you a chatty
we play back my set from the night so
I'll put that on I go check out if you
like the question one I didn't hear that
it said it was their dirty talk d are
you a not really I mean I remember this
last one I whispered a little bit no
like you feel good I like being with you
would you like to go - yeah exactly jet
light and polite I mean what do I want
to like get like I want to like I want
to get do it's too much I'm a big guy
I'm but you know you could read it you
can read it I'm Mabel I play off people
but I was honestly I was happy with
myself because I still got it was eye
sore the next day yes for two or three
days but now I'm back I'm feeling good
well yeah go ahead Sam sore for - yes
I was like like it was like a UFC thing
almost I was trying to like really I was
trying to pin her is that wrong see I'm
getting out of control
passionate violent what are you trying
to get me in trouble who am i a producer
for a diversity showcase is she a repeat
customer was your follow up there's a
text and and Sam Tripoli Sam we're
playing Houston in December what club
who's headlining you got it I just made
an extra thousand bucks off that because
I took a chance so yes but honestly I
probably wasted a lot of money on
supplements but I do feel I mean now
you've found the right recipe you found
the right sort of dosages for all these
things
why take BIOS ill which is good for hair
skin and nails my nails are strong I
mean they're a little I didn't take it
today so what I'm saying is you notice
from day to day
yeah if you take by I'll give you a BIOS
ill tablet you take bio cell and I would
say maybe 90 minutes less than 90
minutes you start feeling your nails do
you take bio so we have an audience
remember are we relating the audience
biotin bio CIL's step-up biotin x' basic
that's for the general population here
bio cell that stuff hey look how dark my
hair is look how thick my beard is
that's from bio silk and I and I'm not
getting cavities so and then I take MSM
that's another one which is sulfur
that's connective tissue that is
detoxification and the reason why I say
that's because we're we're comedians and
our body is our tool it's our temple and
I feel that I got to go for it but and
in terms of like can I ask about ask me
all the questions I'll movements solid
that's the other thing now you're saying
well Brodie you take these supplements
you must be a health freak
I eat eat not well meaning that after
the comedy store after I have a good
amount with the guys no I will I go to
McDonald's I go to Wendy's I go to
Burger King
I go to Del Taco Wendy's just put me
down I was I've been in Atlanta working
on and a movie
yeah I went got sick of the catering
went to a Wendy's and got sick when they
told me you know you're an idiot because
you went to a Wendy's with the old sign
a lot about an owner who won't pony up
for the new logo and the new materials
and what happened you got sick went down
Dave single are you serious three days
yes so you got food poisoning three days
I've had food poisoning on two occasions
Embassy Suites Super Bowl week
Jacksonville Eagles versus Patriots I
was there I had food poisoning
I missed a gig I never missed gigs best
damn sports show who filled in for me
Ken uber remember Ken oh of course yeah
the late can Ober host a remote control
because I had food poisoning Embassy
Suites I had to be I took they took me
the hospital I had an IV right there in
Jacksonville then I had food poisoning
maybe a year ago Wendy next who's me
Jack in a box Laurel Canyon
I had a sourdough burger they didn't
cook it enough ate it sat in my stomach
got sick had to cancel a main room spot
and Adam Egan yeah d'etat yeah so I got
food poisoning
wow that's rough but so you don't eat
well but you take all these supplements
and their balances apple cider vinegar
let me explain
al and you're a good guy apple cider
vinegar what it does it doesn't allow
for food say Wendy's or Burger King to
bind to your fat like the start it
doesn't allow for it to buy and become
something so I've lost inches people
constantly say I went from 36 32 to 34
Wow without exercising so there's
something to it
sure but you need to
what's that yeah I got shorter Sean
Conroy everybody New York Knick fan one
of the hosts of the longshot podcasts
I've known Sean Conroy for over 20 years
Sean do you take supplements no and are
you happier yeah all right I do what the
baseball guys do see in my mind I'm
still playing I'm still baseball but my
hand here's the other thing my
hamstrings hurt and that's from not
exercising so I need to exercise but I
do what the baseball guys do you know I
still feel that I could pitch you know
Satchel Paige pitched when he was 59 is
any of this stuff gonna show up on a
test if you were taking all these things
and being drug tested or you gonna have
a problem with the NFL you're gonna have
a problem with the NBA I possibly could
but you know what what do you think
about the NFL with all this stuff going
on I don't get political but what do you
think about cuz you're a big football
guy sure and we and we've we went on the
oddball tour and we did some football
stuff correct what do you think about
this the CT the CT II was gonna say CT a
Chacon what do you think about the
Chicago Transit Authority in football
okay and obviously these protesting 's
and then even had recently the owner of
the Texans the Oilers yeah the Texans
owner of the Houston Texans distributors
said in in these meetings that they had
with players so they had he was Anquan
Boldin I Bouldin somebody who's first of
all I forget which owner was calling him
antwuan the entire times I was yeah and
then the owner of the Texans just had to
apologize because he said since when are
we letting the inmates run the prison
bad choice of words he should have said
detainees yes right is what he should
have said no you can't say prayer I
don't know what he was thinking yeah
yeah what it was what are we letting the
slaves are on the plantation he can't
know that's what he said pretty much so
the problem is that you have
these rich white owners I told you I got
to do that gig I get to roast the NFL
owners before a Super Bowl 50 you did
yeah
so as we I looked out and it was just
the owners and they can't relate to
anything so what do you say to it owners
they go hey don't you guys hate when
your chef gets in a fight with your
pilot yeah where they can't relate to
anything I know I was trying to just
sprinkle some roast jokes and they were
very sensitive Jerry Jones heckled me at
one point he did yeah I got a Jerry
Jones is here tonight ladies and
gentlemen don't do it he said don't do
it
right out of the gate now don't even
think about it buddy don't don't do it
cuz he thought it was Friday all right
two strippers like first of all I
submitted all my jokes to the 49er
president and he's like oh that's great
you can't do it you can't do it you
can't do it and it was a rough rough
rough gig how long how much time did
about 20 25 and the lineup was Jeremy
Renner me great comedian Jeremy Renner
me Steve Miller Band and my first joke I
went out and I said how about the dinner
huh folks at French Laundry wasn't that
amazing if anyone wants an extra plate
Marvin Lewis didn't finish his man that
guy can't finish anything huh and one
one person is when whoa tough so dig now
so these people these guys who are
catered to constantly these guys who
have their own little ecosystems of yes
men who are just basically saying
anything and everything to appease them
at all times I mean just say they're all
billionaires even the ones that you know
whose grandfathers won the team in a
poker game they're all billionaires
because the teams have so much value
right so they have people just catering
to them non-stop
they're all big Trump supporters or
they're just you know for the most part
the Republicans because you know they're
voting with their pocketbooks there's
huge implications if the wrong candidate
gets into office and starts passing tax
law that's on the front oh yeah now they
get tax breaks for exactly so they're
getting ridiculous amount of tax breaks
and they know they love this better than
anyone but they also have to align
themselves and I
just I don't understand why the national
anthem is part of any sporting event at
all it's not we we don't sing it before
a comedy show
there's no you want you know national
anthem before a concert doesn't make any
sense the Greenwood what's it doesn't
make any sense that it's before a
sporting event I think it all came about
because I think the armed services were
trying to Armed Forces were trying to
recruit and use it as a recruit I'm just
trying to remember what the origin of
the national anthem being sung at these
events is right it was a recruiting tool
for a while but it just doesn't make any
sense and I don't think that
these players are disrespecting the flag
at all and I don't think they're
disrespecting any of the you know
servicemen that are you know risking
their lives or soldiers that are out and
for the sake of freedom in our country
but if we're truly gonna be free it just
doesn't matter they should be able to do
whatever the they want I'm not in
I'm not into it
you don't like the kneeling no I don't
watch I'm out Willie
you're out don't like it I think because
they're doing it it's a big fu that's a
way I feel yeah I'm not saying don't
protet wear t-shirt walking in protest
after the game when you protest during
the national anthem and they are doing
it as a nephew to the flag look at the
NFL the NFL wants to be its own
government look at their the NFL shield
the emblem I get it you're doing by the
anthem you're doing a big F view to me
so I'm offended they could say like
other people aren't me personal what do
you think what the anthem shouldn't even
be I like it then what about God Bless
America take me out to the ballgame I
feel like these are to bring you have a
group of anywhere from let's say even
though high school game 502 we get all
worked up 500 to a thousand people or
whatever it is I feel like when you're
singing it doesn't have to be the anthem
it could be something else I feel like
something bring people together in a
community and binds people together yes
and it doesn't have to be the anthem it
could be a
state anthem it could be god bless
america
it could be city should have its own
song which would be incredible what
about the Pledge of Allegiance what did
you think about that in classrooms you
think that was good or bad no I don't
I'm sorry I'm not I've never been into
it at all see I have but that's just me
but that's the sports guy I remember
being the very little thinking this is
ridiculous not me yeah we when
you probably always the guy reluctantly
taking off my hat looking around with my
hand over my I'd always take it off but
that's what I was taught at baseball
like major league baseball you better be
out there Joe Torre I learned this from
Joe Torre he won't leave the dugout
until that until that like if it's a
military guy he's there until they leave
the field you know there's little things
that I learned from going to all these
games I saw how it mattered but I'd say
I feel the same way about religion I
don't need to go to church to be
religious either I don't need you don't
have this doesn't need to be ceremony
about it for me
I respect the flag I completely do I
respect all of the people that have
fought to protect it that's part of it
yeah that's only part of it sure and I
respect what this country stands for
however I mean how we got here and how
you know you look people's history of
the United States and how we sort of ran
people out and how we took it didn't
come about in the best way
and what's done is done but still I mean
there's a lot of things that have been
done I didn't deliver this flag not me
I'm as a guy sure I'm Jewish I like I
said I got anti-semitic jokes big nose
gay okay I pray for you because I'm a
good person
and you know you're a good person that
means you're not a good person well
I am a good person and I'm a sinner so I
don't so when you I don't like it's a
nephew to me so man you can do that and
I could not watch football rolling at
these meetings talking about how his
brother was shot whose brother
Anquan Boldin what was he doing great
shot innocently I don't what was he
doing I want to know and then I'll go
with it so what do have it I mean what
16 17 black men and no just all the cops
how many black guys shoot white guys I'm
just saying let's call it I got it I
don't I don't I just look at stats I
look at stats I look at behaviors yeah I
raise like they're well within their
right to do whatever they want this is
good podcasting yeah and I know that
there I'm just saying I played baseball
I'm around baseball I like it and this
is how baseball players so I'm a big
proponent of everybody do whatever they
want their freedom or eight people I
don't care I didn't do it there's where
I draw the line I don't like when I go
to Starbucks and guys are playing dice
on the table I mean I deal with it
because I'm at Starbucks I made that
choice I don't like it I can easily tell
the kids try hard and be nice I don't
care about anything that falls outside
of that and that's it I don't give a
about anything else I don't care if
your trains gay yeah you can be gay you
could be a woman I'm saying me
personally you could mean I'm not I'm
not into that yeah I don't give a
but I think it causes divisive nastagio
for example he said the president you're
a bum or whatever after yeah that stuff
he could have said you know what can I
have a medium you know they want to meet
with the owners all the players why
doesn't only Bron James go I want to
meet with the president he could have
why then why are they meet then why are
they then why are the NFL players
meeting with the owners there's no point
then they're Republican they're all
Trump guys see you're getting you're
getting emotional
by saying that LeBron James could have
said President Trump I've got some
issues
I'd like to go into it with these guys
cuz I have to go to do some across the
street al Madrigal God we got real this
gets me talking insid I'll see you buddy
that's what he plumbs sean connery
stepping up to the dish to face Steven
Brody Stevens and I lose fans I lost a
follower today on Twitter al Madrigal
right there Brody your good guy al
you're not upset are you this is good
this is good real Oh No the meeting here
comes the meeting they're gonna pull the
plug on this this is how Sean Conroy
stepping up yes so what did you think
about that when I mentioned I'm talking
sports yeah I know I love sports you're
a Knicks fan I am it's been difficult
for the last 25 years what do you think
about all the changes Phil Jackson's
gone glad Phil Jackson is gone he was
terrible for the team he was right yeah
why they why day he was like almost does
you think he's this amazing you know
he's the he's the Guru right he was yeah
but he's a little you know he's almost
70 little out of touch did all this with
the Bulls and the Lakers and he wasn't
coaching the team he was the GM which
was not how he did it at the Bulls and
the Lakers and he wasn't even there
right half the time right he was like in
Montana or even LA and then he would
like meditating I'm glad he's gone he
took the bus then they catch him
sleeping on the bus no they did really
yeah Sean all I do is follow sports yeah
Phil Jackson was sleeping on a bus now I
know people got upset with me with what
I said at least I was being honest now
what did you think about the LeBron
James thing you're a big basketball guy
I am a big basketball guy and I think he
you know he said what he had to say I
mean that's okay do you think he could
do some like posi as it she has a
platform for positivity a chance to do
some once agrees which I think he's
using yeah he's using the platform for
positivity negativity to positivity
through negativity well
relationship to that he's doing other
things in the community that are giving
computers to kids whatever it may be not
into it but I'm just being honest
Tommaso my Brody Shawn Conroy I've known
you for 20 years yes stand up in New
York
yes people don't realize that when I say
I lived in New York they're shocked oh
you're a valley guy there for a while
I lived in New York for three years I
felt like if you live in New York for
three years
you're considered a New Yorker first
time I've ever met you you were working
at the door at the Comedy Cellar yeah
people don't realize that Brody Stevens
worked at the integral part of the city
yeah because yeah Greenwich Village like
if you're out there barking because they
barked at the Comedy Cellar
I wasn't performing there I had hopes of
performing the last Barker did perform
was Lewis Shaffer so the guy who was
working there he said Brody I think you
can get on stage if you bark if you bark
they're kind of thing yeah as he goes
Manny the owner he's giving me he wants
me to perform on stage and he goes I'm
not ready but I think you are I think if
you go down there you can get a job and
get past did that work out no because I
was intimidated by SD the owner or she
ran she ran the Comedy Cellar and I just
didn't have the confidence to like ask
for a showcase right you seem like a guy
who lacks confidence
why do mm-hmm wait wait Shawn I do
mm-hmm
when I go into Starbucks I'm very quiet
but I was intimidated say your name
again sir please I didn't hear you
Steven okay I put Steven on my thing but
I was intimidating the other thing is
that all the comedian's that was almost
their first impression of me in New York
they're seeing me barking right so when
I actually moved out to Los Angeles say
like two years after that they would see
me go oh I didn't know you did stand-up
yeah it was hard to it's hard to bridge
that gap between the guy who's barking
and the guy who actually does stand-up
yeah I mean that's their first
impression right same thing with like
audience warm-up they see you doing
warm-up and then they're surprised oh
you do stand-up also yeah it isn't
warm-up kind of stand-up though
um there's elements of it I mean for
warmup the elements of stand-up are
crowd work right and then probably jokes
when need be like there's definitely
crowd work and jokes for audience
warm-up but it's different from doing
stand-up yes because they have to laugh
it's more rhythm when I do when I do say
you know I did Chelsea or did @midnight
it's all rhythm see how it's all rhythm
laughs laughs push laughs break push
push push so I'm like constantly doing
that laughs I'm like I orchestrate the
audience you're the conductor yeah kinda
wears when you're doing stand-up you're
the leader
but I'm not conducting them you know
you're not forcing anybody to do
anything
exactly whereas like when you're doing
warm-up I'm almost like forcing them
with energy that's somehow you look like
a magician well I do the hand stuff I
mean you could actually like throw it on
you throw that energy I feel that and I
would five servings of greens just hit
me in the face that's the biggest laugh
of the show but you know people joke
about this energy and I wouldn't say it
if I didn't see results like why am I in
the hangover I never thought I'd be in a
movie but they put me in why am i on
Google Street Maps you never thought
you'd be in Google Street Map never
thought it would be but why do I have a
major league why do I have a baseball
card never thought I would but you do
yeah and like when you I know I'll
mention something about like you do
these things and it you know you want to
get gets laughs but I also feel like you
know John Wooden would say it's not
about winning it's the preparation it's
the you know it's the jokes the
preparation well that waiting will be a
result of that that was in his pyramid
of comedy yeah that's funny thank you
John wouldn't a permit a success so it's
like it goes all the way down for like
how you tie your shoes I try to go for
scure references for the most
well I get them but it's how you tie
your shoes how you said how you wear
your hat how do you present yourself all
those things and the discipline and then
the result would be winning now where
did I learn that John Wooden where is he
where did he live in my neighborhood I
learned that from that Joe Torre I
worked at Joe Torre baseball camp so but
if these things I wouldn't be a
proponent of them if I if it met with
like a lot of resistance
I do get little resistance but I've seen
enough like we're enough people that I
know have you know benefited they've
told me you know same thing with the
warm-up like I get the guys they come in
and they'll say Brody makes a difference
when you're there because you connect
the crowd with me and I've done enough
these stand-up shows we have the fake
audiences in there and you're up there
doing your stand-up and they're not
connected because they're paid so
they're there to act like they're happy
then if they're your VIP friends they're
kind of weird so my goal is a warm-up
was always to especially when they're
stand-ups on the show to have that
audience find the funny don't fake it be
real but also be a little extra
supportive knowing that these guys are
on TV and then do you give out candy
when you're doing warm-up only if it's
like over 90 minutes to two hours now
you have do you have the audience
compete in like silencing I don't ever
do that I don't do I would feel like at
midnight for example 45 minute taping if
you can't be away from candy for 45
minutes or I have to give you candy to
laugh at guys who are you know you'd pay
money funny or 20 bucks to 30 bucks to
see any so I gotta give you candy I
don't play that game so but two hours I
would do candy never do the sing-alongs
because I've been I've been in a lot of
sitcom tapings where that's what it's
all about
Oh compete for this and do this and well
I've done that for certain kind of shows
but like let's say Chelsea Lately and at
those are like panel shows and the
laughs are you know rhythm
no candy different from us and those are
also limited time like you know you're
gonna be done in 45 minutes or an hour
at those shows
yeah where's this whereas the sitcom
taping can go you know four seven eight
and I don't do him because you're under
so much they're not used to it when I
did at midnight or Chelsea she gave me
so much freedom to kind of like push and
do all this whereas a sitcom they
wouldn't do that and I feel like look at
the success of Chelsea Lately at that
time and all the comedians from that
show have gone on to do stuff and they
would come up to me and they go Brody
makes a difference when you're here so
that's what kind of Justin force is like
okay I'm on the right thing and it was
just about that's what the positive
energy comes from you can't walk into a
TV taping being negative this frickin
sucks this crowds at a terrible day and
that was another reason why maybe you as
the warm-up comic can't do that correct
because I walk into tapings like that
all the time
there you go yeah but I have to come in
happy same thing with Mike when I was
doing everyday you know having to be at
that studio at say two o'clock every day
it takes you out of auditioning Howell
and I were talking earlier about how
warm-up might affect your standup not
only does it affect your stand-up in
terms of like how you feel but also you
know you can't be late
you could be late to a stand-up I'm
running late TV won't wait you have to
be there so did you have to audition for
The Hangover I did actually
and how did you do that with your
schedule of warm-up comedy I might have
had an off day I might have gone and oh
I would make an example I mean I would
make I would make you would make an
example out of that audition yes
no I would make what's the word
exceptions exception thank you Eric
exceptions because let's say if you have
an audition in LA and you're you know
you live in the valley maybe you got one
in Santa Monica one downtown one in
Hollywood I got to get to the West good
day at two o'clock yeah but now you're
stressed going to your
gig you have to get to your job on time
where they also put you on the show so I
would be on the show too so I felt like
I had to do that but the sacrifice was
the auditioning did they tell you the
show was better when you were on it or
yes they did
oh when I was on it or when I did when
you were on it I know when you were
warming him up you they were like you
you know I'll tell you why it wasn't as
good because I wasn't doing warm-up for
myself
oh so it was like it was like a catch-22
if you were on the show the audience
wasn't as good if you were doing the
audience you couldn't be on the show
there's truth to that yes there was
times first few times I would do them
warm up warm up the crowd first segment
they go guys
stay right there I'm gonna go on the
show so now I'm on the show and they
don't have it was like the last wouldn't
be there as much if you had not said
stay right there do you think the
audience would have left when you left
they would have left me mentally I said
stay right there with me stay connected
with me mmm so when I did that the first
few times with me not doing the warm-up
it made a difference not good and then
we had then they started bringing in a
warm-up when I would be on and because
the warm-up guy he wasn't there all the
time like me even that wasn't good so
the bottom line is yeah I'm a good
warm-up and it makes a difference but
hey Brody yeah we got about 15 minutes
left and as a big fan of the long shot
myself mm-hmm and Brody being a baseball
guy Shawn you've made some shocking and
disparaging comments about the sport
about baseball yes I would like you to
hash that out with Brody for a second
okay oh yeah there's a rumor going
around
go ahead Shawn that you sleep well I
just have a joke in my stand-up where I
say I watched a baseball game the other
day well that's cool for interesting
thing happened things in three hours for
interesting I can't do my act offstage
but anyway in in three hours for
interesting things happened and three of
them were me getting a beer like I find
baseball so relentlessly boring on TV or
going to it going to it is fine because
you don't have to pay attention to the
game you're with people you like you're
hanging out you're outside it's like
going to a park but paying more you know
but going to the okay so watching on TV
you're not you don't watch everything on
TV now okay either do I mm-hmm
but I had baseball on in the background
I know what's going on see people always
say that but my I can't do that my brain
doesn't work that way like I can't focus
on two different things at the same time
I can't have something and then be doing
something else because I'm like what's
going on over here
oh I should be doing this so I turn off
see a baseball game I was not watching
see I feel like the Dodgers in Los
Angeles it's such it's more than its
it's like the weather it's like the
weather it's part of the news I like to
know what's going on with current events
I know that not saying I have to watch
every inning or not know but I like like
I said I'd like to know have in the
background but I feel like baseball
provides structure it provides
inspiration you know it's it's about
failure it's dealing with you know you
fail it isn't that any sport like
couldn't you do that with a more
exciting sport like football or
basketball or hockey or curling so
football what if football I guess is
exciting you know the hitting I suppose
and but people are down on football
because of all the penalties and all the
rules
some people are down on it and if you
watch now they say football you go to a
football game it's not fun because the
television timeouts and I think it's a
long time but I find going to a football
game more fun than going to a baseball
game
oh now you're doing that too mm-hmm why
is a football game more fun than a base
because when the action on the field is
actually happening there's stuff going
on and you get to see what's happening
whereas baseball is like a bunch of
dudes standing around waiting for
something to happen see I don't think so
what about a foul ball you ever get your
foul ball it again never caught a fire
you ever in an area where a foul ball
might come yes is that exciting I mean
if I had caught a foul ball that would
changed my whole outlook on sports I'll
tell you what I've caught three foul
balls and I've been to hundreds of games
I make always excited about that ball
coming to me and when a ball hits in the
crowd they're buzzing there's 20 people
buzz who thought they were so close yeah
there's something about catching the
ball and then football you don't catch a
ball basketball you don't catch a ball
there's snow you know and even in
batting practice guys or catch it's
something about catching that ball so
what you're saying basically though I
like all balls but also it's that in
that moment in that boring game you have
a moment where you get to be part of the
game that's what makes that moment
exciting yeah I mean I like wow I like
the sounds of the game - I like the foul
crack of the bat I like to crack of the
bat I like the buzz of the crowd I like
the I like the culture of baseball but I
have a different you also played
baseball exactly I played so it is in me
yeah that makes a difference but I like
you know for me pitching for the in
terms of playing as a pitcher and then I
have a see a guy hitting like it's
one-on-one it's like you're gonna you're
gonna step in and like there are those
moments or you got a pitcher throw in a
hundred miles an hour and then I hit her
trying to hit that's pretty intense
right yeah disagree no but I just it
doesn't do anything for me you know and
you got those other seven guys just like
all right can we just have something
happen come on now what about basketball
you think he's exciting to watch a
free-throw make or miss that's exciting
what okay so you're actually sherry
picking free-throw yeah out of the
entire game yes as one thing yes because
there's a lot more of the game in ten
free-throws and yes I passing I do find
free-throws exciting because I was never
good at them and I like watching people
do it well so free throws are kind of
like I almost failed seventh grade
because I couldn't shoot free throws you
know what's better this is what's boring
about basketball free throws and then
all these little timeouts at the end you
know with the watch the forth at the end
of the game the most exciting part of
the NBA basketball I don't disagree I
think they could do things to clean up
last couple
it's got it but there's 46 minutes
before that that's thrilling what do you
think about all these players the player
movement like nobody knows who these
guys are as much as so many what are you
talking about what I'm saying is there's
a lot of you means free agency a lot of
free agent except Thank You Aaron free
agency not yet has what a faded baseball
but it's I think more prevalent in
basketball well here's what's
interesting about that to me and it
might not be interesting to anybody else
but I feel like when I was a kid there
were teams that I rooted for I was a
Giants fan a Knicks fan a Yankees fan
and a range Islander fan island oh but
that was only because everybody I went
to school with was a ranger fan and I
wanted to with them and that was
when the Islanders were winning all the
Stanley Cups but now I have a bunch of
nephews who are huge basketball fans
huge football fans but they're fans of
players not of teams so they follow
certain players no matter what team they
go to is that better is it worse that's
worse I think why is that worse I think
it's worse because in its individual you
know I remember the Showtime Lakers I
remember the Bulls winning you know the
Spurs are winning and I Warriors are
winning those are good teams also but
there's so many superstars on one team
like with the I just feel like I
remember I like the Showtime Lakers I
like the team team aspect you think they
would like fantasy you're you're
cheering for a rival to do well but I
want my visual warriors yeah so NBA
basketball like one player could you
know dominate a game so I like I don't
know I'm just more I was always Showtime
Lakers Clippers never into I tried to
like the Clippers the Clippers don't win
you know why because the people like the
Clippers aren't from Los Angeles they're
bringing their own energy in LA Lakers
even though they came from Minneapolis
back in the day their realtor they're
part of the core part of the culture
inbred I feel that's because they won so
much in the 80s and LA is such a
bandwagon city that everybody all of a
sudden loved Lakers
well they're good in the 70s too then
they went down and then magic came back
but the Clippers haven't done anything
other than you know a couple playoff
victories and I think they don't win
because the people that come to LA are
magnets for show business or magnets for
action doesn't win base excuse me
doesn't win basketball games
no but action wins baseball games action
wins baseball games I really do feel
like a city's energy affects the sports
teams you know you look at the Seattle
Mariners they don't win mm-hmm what's
seattle known for anger clouds and anger
Timothy
and the Seahawks look at the Seahawks
they don't oh wait well they won yeah
but they in my mind they won all those
guys are on pills
speed up pills that was that astroturf
it was just like they they won by sheer
pushing I don't think they won by that's
up football works well got to push the
other guy out of the way I don't I don't
feel that I just feel like football this
is the Seahawks winning it was just a
perfect magical moment for them to get
that so I'm not gonna hate you they did
it despite the energy of the city I'm
gonna say Seattle's Seahawks tapped into
the negative energy of Seattle so they
won the Super Bowl but then next year
because they are negative they were
punished so way I look at it you look at
the Yankees what's the capital of the
world what City New York Madrid oh sorry
New York City those Yankee fans they're
into it they new york cares they have
passion why do the Yankees have 27 or 28
or 29 World Series championships for the
American League champion it's not buy
it's not a flu I would have been excited
if the if the Yankees had beat the
Astros in the playoffs I would have been
excited about that World Series there
you go that would have changed my
outlook I but that's because it would
have connected me back to when I was a
kid and I didn't know any better and I
loved baseball because that was the
first sport so you did when you were in
US when I was little and didn't know any
better yes my grandfather's of
big Yankee fan so he took me to Yankee
Stadium when I was like four years old I
started going to Yankee game so it's in
you and the only World Series game I
ever went to was Dodgers Yankees oh man
1978 it was the game where Reggie
Jackson stuck his hip out and knocked
the ball into the outfield
I remember scored you were there I was
there that was that was that's an iconic
you know so that would have been fun if
the Yankees and the Dodgers played in
the World Series would and I would have
watched it but you know other than that
who cares so we're talking yeah I
distinct fan we know again it's coming
back to the positive energy you look at
San Diego Padres they don't win why
chicken San Diego chicken because
they're happy in San Diego and you've
got people from all over the country in
San Diego so there's no real feel same
thing with Arizona somewhat with the
Diamondbacks a little bit nobody's from
here what about the Brewers Brody
Milwaukee Brewers they've been there
they have a solid fan base the Brewers
are always competitive they care they've
been there's a long history of baseball
in Milwaukee
you know Cub fans here's the thing with
the Cub fans they're happy Chicago is
known for improv we're happy we're
smiling they don't want any kind of
crazy drama so the Cubs so you think the
Cubs success is related to the improv
scene in Chicago lack of success
oh they're less are their lack of
success the reason why I mean success or
not success is related to the fact so if
they took the improv out of Chicago yes
Cubs would be better well the fans would
demand it the fans they would be like I
can't go see an improv show I better
have a good baseball team well is that
an oversimplification of somewhat
somewhat what I'm what I'm getting at is
Chicago's happy second city oh yeah yeah
that doesn't win baseball games you need
fans who get pissed get supportive I
went to the World Series last year in
Chicago I went to the World Series games
with the Yankee stadium's I've been
there when the Cubs were they're excited
and the minute they were down there
and got scared babies Yankees they're up
the whole time we push we push now the
Cubs
yeah but the Yankees have won 27 World
Championships okay the Cubs have the
Bartman game to go back to gotta get
over it I mean Red Sox got over it they
pushed through now they've won three I
mean they they're passionate maybe two
by the way have you ever been to a show
at second city in Chicago because you
basically summed up their shows as
they're happy you happy there's a lot
more complicated stuff that goes on in
those shows you're you're very devoted
to baseball I've done a lot of I've done
a lot of stand-up ago would you say the
Midwest is a happier place than a host I
have not lived there so I don't know I
couldn't say that's my theory from going
to being at Cub Games for the last five
years being at Dodger games being at
Yankee Stadium Cubs it's friendly it's
happy players feed off that now you get
a winning culture and you get guys in
there who are like pushing it through
changing the demeanor of the players the
fans pick up on that and they win Cubs
got the three years in Roach and see the
championship series against II don't but
one of the coaches there they're like my
friends a big-time coach and he's from
the valley it's certain its blue-collar
tough nosed we're not here to party
we're gonna win games and he's a winner
he won what the yeah how tough is his
nose it's very tough but when see what
when it was with the Yankees he was
there for 12 years the Yankees you're
expected to win if you didn't win two
out of three games in a regular season
series it was panic George Steinbrenner
George Steinbrenner as much as he was
like hated and a tough guy guys were on
their toes and you it was expected to
win Cubs are now they're starting to
expect the win but that's how you have
to think and I felt like they didn't
have that winning culture there you go
but the fans need to adapt that and take
their scared
yes and go let's go in push like I think
the Astro fans they're into it even
Dodger fans are into it
Dodger fans are pretty passionate would
you say would you disagree would you
agree I would say any fan base that's in
a championship series is gonna be pretty
passionate you know I just worry I don't
just a lot of people kicking back going
World Series game last year and people
were like yes once they were down there
like out I guess I didn't see those
people and some people were on Twitter
this year with the Cub fans losing to
the Giants I said or did the Dodgers
then go look at all these Cub fans
leaving early I'm not ripping Cub fans
I'm just rip I'm saying like I disagree
with you do you have gifts for people is
that what's going on do you know
baseball I mean I did a long time follow
it now no not at all no could you name a
player on the Mets right now rusty Staub
he's not on there anymore
I want you Tom Seaver I want you to pick
a card randomly okay and see if I can
guess it this is what we called a
baseball card game this is what sets
this podcast this game sets this podcast
apart this is what it does all right so
I'm picking a card if I pick a card let
me see if I can see who it is but I
apologize if I offended anybody we might
have to do some edits on this podcast no
not even with the okay what's your name
Victor's here Matt Andy
Charlotte Alex we got four fans on a
Saturday morning that's devotion that's
two more this is Oh more in the back but
are you fans also you work here we have
what's your name where are you from
where'd you go to high school Lake
Michigan Kalamazoo heard it that's where
Derek Jeter's from that's where General
Mills is from got it Andy you Ord you go
to high school
Providence in Burbank no where's that
Illinois heard of that talking about the
Cubs there is a Providence High School
in Burbank Victor were you from Arizona
I believe it could give me a city
Phoenix heard of it can you give me a
street van Buuren heard of it that's
where they filmed the Morrissey video
you know that Morrissey video there's a
Morrissey song and he's driving down Van
Buren look it up I forget the song I'm
right what high school is on Van Buren
this is why you're on Google Maps by the
way I am on Google Maps I'll show you
guys Google Street View my grandmother
went to Phoenix Union High School it's
not there anymore I think was on Van
Buren you're a good guy Victor what's
the guy named behind you Matt where you
got a good voice you do radio locally oh
you live here in Vegas
yeah were you staying at Mandalay Bay I
want to have some information on you
what floor where'd you go to high school
Waterville we got like a lot of
interesting crowd here Maine that's like
near Kennebunkport there were the bushes
would hang out near a ghost State though
same state heard of it University in
Maine the black bears correct okay and
what brought you out to Vegas you work
at a casino you do security oh you are
oh you have a demo tape I'll help you
I'm here wearing pajama pants and the
condo are you and laser
pajama pants and a blazer doing clown
work and then Andy or your lady friend
what's your name again Sharla it's a
beautiful name I read a book Charlotte's
Web and my favorite band is Good
Charlotte and I have a show next week in
Charlotte North Carolina there's so many
connect the Charlotte trifecta
there you go Charlotte and where did you
grow up Charlotte heard of it been there
Lincoln Omaha won $500 at a riverboat
casino
what city yep Auburn that's a good
college how small they're like 40,000
and 3,500 I dated a girl who grew up in
a Nebraska town of 200 people there's
some small towns there 200 people Wow
and then how did you guys meet on
FarmersOnly colwich college Purdue State
Oh is that down in South America
Lima look at the victor having a great
time now what bro you look familiar were
you here like the other day are you big
podcast fan you like you do comedy also
you're a good guy why what do you how do
you stay so positive Victor we're gonna
wrap it up what's that
Victor stays positive through me he said
that Shawn pick out pick out a card let
me wrap this and I picked one already
okay give me so did you want me to pick
it from the deck that you cut and gave
me a special part of pick a card any
card let me see if I can fit in to pick
another one sure okay good see if I can
name them got it this is like this is
the game sweeping the nation
all right so how do you what do I have
to do Brodie like you are you just gonna
guess I'm like what's his religion
what's his VIN number maybe give us a
team in position yeah Aaron's good at it
he's the mission so he is on the
Mariners oh they're lazy negative and
he's a pitcher what years does it say
what you because these are these are
traditional traditional courts let's see
boy the print is very small on this here
let me see
is he right-handed Victor do you know
baseball kid Victor Victor get up on the
mic with Shawn help me out here and
we'll wrap this thing up go knock over
the monitor talking to Mike Victor for
the Mariners 90 Mariners 90 Giants 89
Giants so Mariners and Giants pitcher
pitcher I can't read any of that by the
way
born in Fremont Calif it's got some eyes
on him home is Kennewick Washington
Bobby L Iowa no sir religion is Wiccan
Mariners and Giants entered pro ball at
Everett in 86 Erin that's a tough was he
is he an all-star no he and his wife are
parents of a daughter okay I know who
that is both him and his wife are
parents of it
is he right right or left he is left
Jamie Moyer that's a good guess 6 4 to
10 left-handed Gemini was drafted by the
Giants in 86 I should know this
yeah it's not Kirk reader nope yeah he's
later
can we give hints your first name Wow
first letter of the name are it's not
Randy Johnson no third no last name your
first letter of the law that we little
yes okay yeah RS RS Oh Russ Springer
almost but no first names right oh right
Oh Russ D Staub call back Ross he's a
third pitcher pitcher Russ s last name
is a type a type of bird type of bird
that's Russ sparrow well I give me a
pick another what's a swallow Russ Swan
I would never guess I wouldn't get that
do one more let's pick and you pick
another one we'll wrap this thing off
Victor everybody welcome to the
podcasting world of Victor yes we had
some ups and downs today 86 Indians yep
catcher Andy oh I saw that one Andy
Allison yes okay here we go
my back is turned yeah that feels
uncomfortable Brodie he plays for the
Arizona Diamondbacks okay Dean team here
he's from Houston Texas who they're in
the World Series yes six to 200 drafted
by the White Sox what years is an
outfielder what year did he get drafted
or yeah or what year is this this is
2017 oh six Diamondbacks oh seven
Diamondbacks Oh 8 dynamics
no there you know what it is who is it
whoa how'd you know that we're done that
well this guy's good
Wow I need that is really good are your
name's Matt how did you know that let's
do one more
so far the so far the people here to see
the podcaster better than you at this
game well these are tough players Chris
Young currently on the Yankees he was
the shara thing he was that was good
Brian
pitcher yep white sox 86 white sox 87
white sox 88 white sox Bobby Thigpen
nice nail that's how you play the game
folks
yeah that's how I got to go out on top
Brody
yeah let's go down that okay we're gonna
go out on that was pretty impressive by
me see ya you were one for five that's a
200 batting average yeah but you know
what that's what baseball's all-star
game
Shawn Conroy keep swinging thank you you
will thank you you have any yeah long
shot podcast today at 6 in this same
space and then I'm going on tour I'm
going on tour all over the country for
the next two and a half months so how'd
you are you serious yeah with zoom we do
you bro don't like it no like I
want to join in yes yes it's me the tour
is called the world's smallest giant
tour that's me and you can find out
details at world's smallest giant calm
is that on WorldStarHipHop nope Wow
let's try I want to hear more about that
tour cuz I would go Victor what do you
want to plug Arizona Diamondbacks
baseball fan so just your positive
energy - that's what that's what drew
him here
he was the magnet of positivity so
that's Victor Aaron our producers does a
great job he helped me out that he said
get through the prayers thank you I went
to CBS I bought all these cards and
Aaron's been supportive and I'm doing a
better job and every Rachel and Oscar
and Al and Noel I went I bit the hand
that fed me today this could be the last
podcast
but I didn't eat yet so I get a little
emotional so let me read this this is I
supposed to ring at the top of the
podcast we're rude three two one we're
recording live from the ATC pop-up
podcast studio in downtown Phoenix at
the all things comedy comedy festival
presented by Bud Light cityscape and
Tito's handmade vodka should do that
again I won't end of podcast so I would
like to say thanks for checking this out
I'm gonna be cranking these podcasts out
the the title and the theme will be
flashed if you remember Seinfeld start
out her Seinfeld Chronicles you know
blink 182 started out as blink 183 did
they really know they were wink 184 is
that a C thomas Howell movie and he was
in it's a Turk 184 so too you could
follow me I'm on Instagram are you I'm
you know yeah I just signed up I'm on
Twitter Brody is me friend based off
Tony and mr. Lee my Busboys in New York
City Brody you good you good guy
umifriend so it's an old man I never
knew the history of that thank you there
you go there's a New York guy so uh
thank you very much everybody had a
great time I'll tell you what this all
things comedy festival I hope it becomes
an annual yes event I think Arizona is
an awesome place to be wouldn't mind if
it you know we go on a traveling
traveling festival yeah you know we'll
take all the dates you got you you you
set the right and I can have somebody
with me so the tour actually makes sense
oh yeah so ladies and gentlemen forget
Brody you will not forget
Sean Conroy a good friend better than a
good friend dare I say a very good
friend and thank we went to jinkies one
day in the early 2000s and I still have
the photos
I'm so glad put them up on Instagram I
will ladies and gentlemen thank you very
much you got it yeah Brody Stephens all
things comedy signing off good guy Brody
push